latest fight against the coronavirus
taking a major leap today
everybody 16 and older can now get the
vaccine our hector mejia is at the
southern nevada health district with the
latest
well today we learned that southern
nevada reached the milestone of
administering more than 1 million doses
and the site here at the health district
is running again
after a water leak issue canceled
vaccination appointments here
that was last friday but that has been
resolved and the southern nevada health
district here offers the first and
second doses to anyone 16 and older now
the overall goal is to get as many shots
into arms now that the largest group of
people
is eligible for the vaccine and so far
27 percent of nevada's population has
received at least the first dose
however the health district says it's
still competing with misinformation
and still floating out there about the
vaccine we just have to constantly
educate the population about the vaccine
and let remind people that it's a it's a
very safe vaccine
it's very effective um and it's free
i came in at 9 45 got the shot
administered at 9
50 and in and out and it was an overall
great experience
a little sore but you know hopefully no
adverse reactions
the health district opens at 7 00 a.m in
case you're looking for an
early morning site before work other
large vaccination sites are located at
the las vegas convention center
at the cashman center over at unlv and
now inside the encore on the las vegas
strip we are told some of those sites
still have appointment availability this
week and if you don't have
transportation
the health district is working with rtc
to provide those with mobility issues
a round trip to their appointment
reporting near decatur and u.s 95 hector
mejia
8 news now